we now have about 15 minutes for some
questions to our panel members and amy's
standing there with a mic so if you want
to hold your hand up she'll bring a mic
to you hi the arguments about the
positive elements of group identity are
very compelling but I think we all know
that there are there's a dark side to
that right it for there to be us quite
often there has to be of them or for to
be accepted and included in a group
there's a certain controlling element
that's not always very healthy so I
would like to hear I suppose the haslums
probably primarily thoughts on that dark
side and what can be done to pursue the
good while mitigating the bad yeah I
mean I think that's absolutely nothing
can touch on that being her talk she
said there was a bit of double-edged
sword I did the first point I just make
is that that is true that groups have
some bad aspects to them but actually
internally in those groups you know
across all the studies it's really hard
to find you know when you do wash the
data through that there's much residual
negative effect of groups there is some
localized up within groups and
particularly groups that have bad norms
and so on the only groups I think we
found that reliably have negative
effects are things like substance abuse
or groups that found it around substance
abuse and stuff like that so if you hang
out with a group of people you'd like to
consume large amounts of alcohol then
that will probably have negative
consequences but even if you take that
group actually the benefits of being in
a group of other people will have pretty
powerful mitigating effects against the
actual substance abuse itself so I mean
I you know and again I'm just taking a
source anticipo to that but you're at
but the other broader issue I think
about how intergroup relations
and I think when Kath was talking about
groups that we have positive identities
where it isn't the you know if I'm in a
bridge club or I'm a soccer club yeah I
have to play with other soccer teams and
probably other bridge clubs which
doesn't mean how to do bad things to
them necessarily so I think there are
and there are certain categories of
identity which are more oppositional and
more conflictual I think broadly
speaking ones that we're talking about
they have these health benefits are not
those types of identities generally
speaking but but you know I mean a good
if you want to take a really sort of
chronic example the Nazi Party was very
good for the health of its members okay
I'm not suggesting that is a good group
and that it has broader benefits for
society or and so on so yeah you want to
interrogate the content of the identity
as well as the fact of the identity
perhaps if I can just follow up on that
further in terms of that last point I
think it's really important in terms of
you know understanding what what a
person's social identity makeup is who
are those groups that people actually
align themselves with and you're right
there are some groups that won't won't
sell positive health messages encourage
greater drinking in a particular context
Allen was talking about people with
addictions earlier on where there's some
work that we're doing with some
colleagues in Melbourne looking about
looking at identity change processes in
the context of recovery from addiction
and what that's looking at specifically
is this mix of the different identities
that people have those that promote
continued use and those that promote
recovery and how you actually feed into
all of those in order to get the best
long-term outcomes but it's recognition
to both of those and the influence of
both of those that I think is important
at a practical level in terms of trying
to produce and encourage positive change
one other quick comment and i just found
this at Edward Wilson's got this book on
the call i think the history of human
existence of the meaning of human
existence in there from an evolutionary
perspective he says the individual at
the individual level evolutionarily the
the selfish will always win out over the
altruist individual a group of alterous
will always went out over a group of
selfish always it from an evolution go
back five hundred thousand years or
whatever come forward that's so that's
the case in evolutionary sense now I'm
not the scientist but this is what was
reported so high I think it's really
interesting to see how the research is
demonstrating how social connection has
health benefits and I'm an occupational
therapist I'm asking this question from
that perspective but I'm wondering if
there's any risk or any down sides of
clinical izing human connection as an as
an intervention I mean ot's have managed
to make brush my teeth a medical
intervention and I'm wondering if we're
losing anything in that process by by
saying you know this is a targeted
intervention at towards a marginalized
population when social inclusion is
really just about an inherent human way
of being I perhaps just one response to
that is that I do think that by medical
izing it it's almost one of the things
that it can invite is it invites people
to actually say to others well you solve
my problem for me so I do think there's
a there's a slight downside to that
because certainly the message that we're
trying to promote is that it's really
important to get people to take
ownership and to enter work on those
social connections I think the problem
with that we faced is that people
haven't taken that mantle on board they
haven't taken advantage of those social
connections so at least in these early
stages maybe we do actually have to
bring it further to the fore to actually
encourage people to take
responsibility and ownership for their
own social connections and two and and
maybe medical izing at some level you
know medical izing it might be sort of
taking a bit far but all we're trying to
do is we're just trying to make it much
more explicit and to hand back some of
that responsibility rather than people
sort of putting it back in the hands of
services or medicos or health
professionals to solve that problem for
them it's really just empowering people
to show them that they've actually got
they can make a change themselves I
think sooo don't think is a very good
question but I also think there's a kind
of political dimension to this if in
that health space you're up against a
whole load of other printing of clinical
types of program and the example I use
of rec link which is a fantastic it with
someone would say we do these things
already but they have their funding cut
because they're not they don't have the
scientific evidence they don't have a
kind of recognized kind of program and
so I think part of what we're trying to
do is to put the again the evidential
scientific bones also a flesh on those
sort of intuitions that people haven't
to formalize it and codify that so that
I think you know there is a standardized
framework against which you can build up
that evidence and I think that that's if
you like part of the politics of this
space and two and just sort of doing it
by rule of farm and and intuitively
while I think that's a very sensible
thing to do I think potentially you end
up self marginalizing in that broader
sort of political sphere so what we're
trying to do is kind of fight fire with
fire if you like
when this follows sort of this
discussion in your 5 s's calf the first
was schooling that seems to me to be a
special sort of generalizable a
component of this sort of treatment
basically it speaks to manage your own
self identity and I wonder if you could
elaborate a bit more on what you did in
that module right the schooling module
was actually educational and the whole
reason for why we incorporate that is
that we take very much for granted the
social relationships that we have and
also what they can achieve for us so
within that module we actually we have
we encourage people to start thinking
about what their what their groups
constitute what makes up a group and
getting people to think about well what
are the benefits of being members of
these particular groups whether they're
part of family networks whether their
work related whether their community
based or religious group based so it's
really getting to people to getting
people to start moving away from from
thinking about individual relationships
to moving on to thinking about group
relationships because often when when
we're in that relationship space we're
often thinking about those one-to-one
relationships we're not often thinking
about the benefits that we actually
going from groups so it's really just
trying to take take those experience
bring those experiences to the fore and
getting people to actually talk about
well what how is it that these groups
actually influenced my life the second
component of that of that module is to
actually start getting to people getting
people to understand that those groups
actually have an influence in shaping
who they are and so it has a very strong
identity focus as well so getting people
to sort of understand what their what
their social networks are but also how
they actually live them out and through
what activities and how does that
actually strengthen those bonds and how
does that that lead them again to
actually source the support from those
particular networks so essentially those
those are the sort of two elements
trying to get people to understand what
their group networks are but also that
those group networks are very intimately
related to people's sense of self I have
a question here and I was really struck
by the term identity centered policies I
haven't heard it and Martin you picked
it up as well and so we're I'm thinking
right now is in the areas of poverty
lamination poverty reduction and social
inclusion bringing those two together
and making recommendations on how to how
to better do social inclusion and so I'm
thinking of identity centered policies I
think I'm thinking about them but my
worry is that we're going to create a
whole new we're all going to walk out of
this room saying identity centered
policies are the way we should go and we
don't really know what that means or I
guess I'm not comfortable with what that
means I don't know how to explain that I
followed the presentations but i guess i
would like you to stay what that looks
like what's on the ground what does that
feel like look like what does that how
would you write one what would it what
would it say yeah i mean i think again
that's a great question i mean i think
again that's relevant to kind of all
kind of leadership in some sense i think
all leadership has to be identity center
in a particular sense and i have talked
about like identity mapping but again
our point is you can't really work with
any population to do anything whether
it's you know play football or whatever
unless you understand what what they're
about and often that's about you know
that's about structured forms of
information gathering if you like and
again we have a range of kind of things
like identity mapping but i always say
like if you were in a leadership space
you know before you can lead a group
find out what's making people tick what
again it was Frank oh gosh you know why
did you come here today you know what
are they know if we'd had a bit more
time you know would have been good to
find out whatever be in the room has
come here what is it what on what what
are the group memberships that have
brought you into this room and so the
extent that we have engaged with those
you've probably found this useful event
but if we haven't and we've misjudged
you and you actually here to find out
more about classical economics then if
it would have been a complete disaster
okay so so again you know really it's
about saying you've just got to have
your radar on in that way
and then you've another of I think
formal ways of assessing where people
are coming from collectively and what
their aspirations are in a very basic
level you can just ask them you know and
again I think it's often lots of the
thing I think that in my mind there are
so many connections across all of the
talks that people were kind of making
about being person-centered and so on
and again and again I think you know
there's lots of those things that we
kind of understand but often we just
sort of fail to do for all sorts of
reasons and one of the things that
happens in the spaces we make
assumptions about people's identities
what makes them tick and if often we
impose identities on them so we assume
that they one of our colleagues at
Brisbane am is doing research on
homeless people whether they self
categorize us homeless is that is this
putt and actually the answer is not a
lot of homeless people don't think of
themselves as homeless that's not so
that's not how they're relating to the
world around them so if you treat them
as homeless well you know if I treat you
all as you know supporters a particular
political party when you're not then
again what I do is unlikely to resonate
with your aspirations and it's unlikely
to be translated into productive forms
of action absolute like just just one
fight just to add to that I think about
it very concretely and in terms of
identity centered policies and at a very
practical level it's about trying to
understand what identities matter to
people and as Alex were saying you ask
that question because those identities
are actually going to influence and
shape how people feel how they respond
to you and to to the wider world so when
we're talking about identity centers
policies it's really just trying to
trying to take on board what identities
matter to people because they're going
to influence what outcomes and they're
going to influence their outcomes but
also they're going to actually shape how
you interact with them we have question
from the webcast audience yes this is
from Elizabeth she says an increase in
victim identity how good or bad is it
for the health of individuals and groups
will actually do tech not sorry in our
culture
just speak on behalf of nyla Branscomb
use another member of a CFL program and
she does a lot of work on for example
members of minority groups and
disadvantaged groups and what are the
benefits or what are the consequence of
them of developing an identity around
there and her research means shows that
that she has a kind of what she calls a
rejection identification model which is
that if you collectively come to
acknowledge your disadvantage that can
be a that can be a buffer from the
stresses and some of the difficulties
associated with that and critically to
it can be immobilized for you to engage
in social change so for example if you
are a group that's been victimized then
you can acknowledge the injustice that's
been done to you and then you can work
together to do something about it and
you think about feminism or something
about for more all sorts of kind of
labor movement type of things which are
around disadvantage and so on where
they've successfully come together to
both remove the stressor and then to
engineer social change and her research
provides a lot of efforts to that so the
broadly speaking it's positive which is
that there is a negative dimension of
course sometimes you don't want to put
your hand up and so on i'm a victim i'm
a member of a stigmatized groups that
there are costs to particularly in
societies where where if you like you're
punished for being a member of that
group and if indeed you're you're in a
toxic environment where people are
politically motivated to eliminate those
groups so they don't like feminists or
whatever it might be or or left-wing
people well then they can take to one
side and they can do bad things to you
so in particular political systems there
are a particular costs but broadly
speaking it's positive so again is the
double edge but broadly speaking that it
is better to identify collectively with
the prospect of bringing around change
than to just you know remain closeted in
some way thank you
how do we have any last questions yes in
terms of the relationship between
individual and group to some extent i
would like to think that and I know
there's berries you know from one person
to the other that the group can
influence the behavior and actions of an
individual but it does not necessarily
control it although I know for some
individuals the group make controller so
it's that home is what I'm saying is
that true that that you know the group
can and I you know I really you know for
somebody who thinks of themselves as you
know being highly you know
individualistic what I like about what I
heard today is how I may have been a
little naive about thinking about you
know the influence of you know all the
social groups that I do belong to you
know in terms of the fact that you know
I did come from another country you know
this is really good about acknowledging
all those identities but but i but I
want to try and understand that a better
group influencing you is different from
a group that controls your behavior so
can I get a response I'm sorry I've just
prevent yeah I mean one of the things is
you have choice because I mean in a
sense we remember again this is Cass
point your members of multiple groups so
I could be a member of I could be
Canadian and I could also be you know
left wing or something and again at
different times those identities may be
exerting differential force on me so in
a sense again that you know a better
particular context one will will exert
more influence on you but I think the
individual isn't lost actually within
the group it's a lot of our research
points to the fact actually you find
voice as an individual in a group and
you get a sense of control and purpose
so there's a kind of an anti
collectivist kind of perspective which
is that you own you ever find yourself
as an individual
you have a choice if you're an
individual and groups take away choice
actually our research shows very clearly
the group's give you choice in part as a
function of the number that you have and
the kind of experiences and richness of
experience that they open up to you so
that it's a really of course massive
question and not just psychology or
politics were also philosophy anyway it
doesn't mean thank you I think we're
ready to take a break now before we take
a 15-minute break I'm going to ask you
to note the location on your name tag
because following the break we're going
to range ourselves in small groups for
some discussion the questions are
located in your group area and I ask
that you pick a volunteer or somebody
volunteer to come back to the room
because we will ask you to report back
some of your key reflections or key
messages from your discussion questions
and for the people on the webcast you
can participate by going to the chat
room and sharing your thoughts with the
questions there so if we could take a 15
minute break and maybe aim to be in our
groups by five after eleven we'll
reconvene here at eleven-forty-five for
the report back thank you